For the rest of
this video segment,
I thought I would go through
a few of them with you
and we'll watch them together.
So let's start with this one.
It's actually a piece of
art, but I immediately
saw the technology involved with
getting those balls floating
in the air.
So it's relevant
for us, I think.
And I think the video
continues to engage us.
I was really drawn to the color
in this particular attempt.
It's quite beautiful, in that
sepia tone-- for me, anyway.
So now we see a hand.
That's interesting.
They are making the video
a little more compelling
by inserting a fourth ball.
OK, it's a good idea
that you run the video
and change it after
a few seconds.
So look what's going on now.
They've cut into a new video
with colored balls, which
is really quite beautiful.
And so we're inserting yet
another iteration of the video
after the first.
And I'm still
fascinated, and want
to look at all those balls.
It's the same set up that
was in the previous video,
but this time colored.
And we're at the very end
now, and there you go.
I thought it'd be fun
for you to just take
a look at this particular one.
The question is
whether or not this
is relevant to your
own video making.
That's your call.
So let's go to the next one.
You're seeing a surface
inside a piece of equipment.
And we see drops of water
forming on the surface.
I gather the researcher first
tried to capture the phenomenon
with angles lighting this.
There were too many reflections
and glare, he mentioned to me.
So in the end what
you're seeing here
is interestingly a ring light.
It's concentric with
the lens, and it's
lighting this surface at a
perfectly perpendicular angle.
I remember that he tried a lot
and wound up with this one.
And we're seeing
that these drops are
coalescing and becoming larger.
And that is in fact the
point of the science.
Later when he sent
it to me, I asked
if he intended to
include in the frame
the left side wall
of the apparatus.
For me it looked kind
of like an accident.
And in fact his
first response was
that he didn't intend
to show the wall,
but after thinking
about it the edge
is very informational
to scientists
who understand
this kind of stuff,
because the edge affects
the motion of the drops.
So for me, I would have
shown even more of the edge.
Great deal of attempts were made
in trying to make this video.
In the end, I think
it's a great job.
So here's something
that's considerably
different from what
we've been seeing before.
We're seeing a flattened
something-or-other become
unflattened totally by himself.
We can sort of guess that -
-that was a bit of a jump.
You can guess that the battery
is making all this happen.
It's somewhat origami-like,
wouldn't you say?
And now he's becoming
even more of a something--
I don't know what to call it.
It really is a robot.
And so these
researchers are doing
some pretty fabulous
stuff, where
you start with a
flattened assemblage that
becomes something else.
And we did speed
this up a little bit,
So that's why you're
seeing some jumps.
There he goes.
Kind of silly, but incredibly
unique and very exciting,
leaving a trail behind
him, by the way.
And finally, this last batch
is a bit beyond the course,
because these videos were
made with a high speed camera.
But I thought I'd get you
excited about your next steps,
in case your work will benefit
from high speed photography.
The point here is, as
we continue to suggest,
is that the way you
approach any kind of videos
should still be
informed by what we've
been discussing for
the past few weeks
on how to make your still image.
I hope you agree about that.